it's sad for people who love the city of
chicago and all americans should it's a
thoroughly american city and a great
place in a lot of ways to see the city's
decline we've talked a lot about the
murder rate the hundreds of people
killed for no reason there every year
we've talked very little about the
physical filth but that's the reality of
life there too
chicago is infested with rats to the
extent that one chicago animal shelter
the tree house humane society is
releasing
feral cats to get the rats under control
for six years in a row orkin has named
chicago as the ratiest city in america
as an alternative to poison the
treehouse humane society
offers the cats at work program
featuring feral cats who prefer to be
socially distant
they will not thrive in a home
environment to hire a cat crew for a
home or business the cost ranges from
600 to 800 dollars
so the shelter is for a fee placing two
to three cats outside of businesses
uh and rhett and residences uh that call
for
help with rats seems kind of inspired
does it actually work well we wanted to
talk to someone who would know the
answer jordan reed is a rat wrangler
he says in fact dogs would be more
effective we wanted to talk to him for a
moment tonight
to put her finer point on that mr reed
thanks so much for coming on
first before you get into your
preference dogs over cats
ferrets maybe describe for us the rat
problem in chicago tonight
well i don't know much about it because
i'm out on the west coast i only know
that i get a lot of phone calls and
emails
on a continual basis inviting me to come
out
right i mean that's that's kind of the
point i mean you're a thousand miles
away
and the city of chicago is reaching
that's how desperate they are
overwhelmed they are
by the norway rat problem tell us when
you hear of people releasing
feral cats to keep rats under control
you chuckle silently to yourself don't
you the ignorance
just a little bit uh feral cats are well
known for
the problems they cause the native
species and they're not known for
catching
yeah i and by the way anybody deeply
familiar with feral cats would know that
so what would you recommend
well i like to promote the use of dogs
and i'm well
known for my work out here in california
and oregon
the use of terriers as well as dealing
with the management problems that's
creating the rats
terriers as they were called in great
britain so long ago ratters
ratting dogs how many how many rats can
a
well-trained ratting dog a terrier take
out in the course of an evening would
you say just
ballpark well i often take my dogs out
for three or four hours but to farm
locations and i've caught well
in excess of several hundred in that
time period with
three or four adult dogs several hundred
well that's remarkable do you let your
dogs eat them
no sir just in case a poison uh training
to drop it is one of the first commands
they learn
yeah so like like a bird dog you don't
eat the quail you drop it at the feet
of of your master and you're dead last
i'm sorry uh i just go around and
collect them after they're dead
what do you do with them uh we give them
to falconers or we compost them
yeah nothing is wasted use the whole rat
i like that
um and last question do you what do your
dogs think of it i mean how proud are
they
after killing 200 rats in a night well i
would answer that question by saying the
reason i have chosen this is my
fun activity is because i'm embracing
the true nature of the dog so it is my
belief that this is
truly in the nature of the animal and
because i like terriers i have to give
them an activity
i love that i love dogs too and i agree
with you completely
jordan thanks so much for coming on
tonight it's great to talk to you i hope
you're coming thanks for having me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else